and the spirit award for best supporting  mail  goes to  paul racy for sound of metal  hey now yeah independent spirit awards  let's all sign that together  independent spirit woo award  wow wow thank you thank you so much  i want to thank amazon  for the love the support the money  i'm just kidding darius martyr thank you  brother  for this opportunity thank yours for  being the best acting partner  ever my wife my daughter my guitars my  band  thank you so much and you know i've been  uh a day player for 30 years here in  hollywood but i have  one little piece of advice i can give  all of you people that are still  struggling here  don't quit your day job i never did  i still have it too  love you guys  you